[Music]
foreign
hello there you're watching the Press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive it's time to
see what's making their headlines with
Kevin McGuire associate editor of the
Daily Mirror and Claire Ellicott acting
Deputy political editor of the mail on
Sunday they'll be with us from now until
just before midnight so let's see what's
on those front pages the eye reports
that Richie sunac could be set to make
far-reaching spending cuts next month
after ripping up every one of his
predecessor Liz trusses economic plans
the garden with the fracking ban
reinstated and doubts again about the
pension triple lock the paper says the
trust's Legacy has been rejected
the express asks do you really want to
scrap the pension triple lock again
according to the Daily Telegraph tax
Rises could again be on the cards
the financial times says the three-week
delay to next Monday's fiscal statement
will give the chancellor breathing space
to work out how best to balance the
books
the times reports that major reforms and
improvements to education are also on
the new prime minister's agenda
The Daily Mail leads with news of the
soaring costs of dealing with the
country's growing migrant crisis
don't be gay at the World Cup is the
lead in the Metro remarks by the foreign
secretary about the tournament in Qatar
which have angered lgbtq football fans
the daily start leads with fears for the
survival of Britain's pigeons as more
and more of them begin to act like
zombies
and finally the sun has a story about
Harry Styles and his recent film co-star
Florence pew
and a reminder by scanning the QR code
that you see on your screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch along with us
well as I say we're touring tonight by
Kevin McGuire associate editor of the
Daily Mirror and Claire Ellicott acting
Deputy political editor of the mail on
Sunday Kevin Clare good evening to you
thank you very much for being with us
all right let's start off with the daily
telegrapher and Claire Telegraph
reporting that that delay of a few weeks
by the chancellor could actually say 15
billion pounds not an insignificant
amount of money
well now I've been fantastic news for
Rishi suda and they're saying the
resolution Foundation have a report out
saying that
um the delay might might mean 10 to 15
billion pounds are saved and that means
that rich you see that won't have to
make those cuts to spending or use tax
Rises to increase that money so that'll
be fantastic news and I think the the
budget shortfall is estimated around 35
billion pounds and that is a frightening
amount of money for a new prime minister
to have to save in some way and um he's
going to face some very difficult
choices even if that money is saved and
how exactly he implements that and Kevin
would you make of this delay I mean it's
a kind of nifty economics isn't it that
just by putting off a couple of weeks
you can save all that money
that actually works out that would be uh
fantastic at two and a half week delay
now because here's first order of the
treasury and a former Chancellor so he
will really want to get his head around
the the figures in some ways you know
Jeremy Hunt do you really want to be the
the chancellor of a former Chancellor I
suspect uh I suspect not but the
telegraphs say he's still looking at
possible tax Rises and spending cuts
which really he spoke in Downing Street
yesterday of difficult decisions
decisions that'll be difficult for other
people
so he's he's got he's a very much a
fiscal cons uh conservative he's very
Orthodox you know it could be incredibly
painful and we we saw today that he in
Downing Street wouldn't commit to
raising pensions by the the triple lock
of about 10 or benefits buying the same
rate and there could be real terms Cuts
in both which I think would reap him not
a political dividend but a political
Whirlwind he would get an incredible
backlash if he does that yeah an answer
to both of those things it was just wait
for this plan which as you understand I
was coming on the 17th of November let's
move on to the guardian now and uh just
another example of the way that those
plans laid by Liz trust best laid plans
by list trust server been laid to waste
by the new PM Kevin
yeah I want to shambles it ah there we
are yeah conservative Manifesto 2019 no
fracking Liz truss in a way brought
herself down by trying to bring back a
fracking whipping her MPS to uh vote
against the labor motion uh maintaining
the the battle that the accusations of
people being manhandled strong-armed uh
they at the following day she was gone
now Rishi suit up is it's back to the
future and no fracking what it what a
mess what a shambles he's got to restore
order in in some way if the
conservatives are going to have any
chance at the next election and regain a
smidgen of reputation uh for being sort
of coherent and and stable but it's
still a mess it's it's a sign of a what
a deep pool uh he he is in but by doing
this he saved lots of his own MPS
Rebellion because nobody wants fracking
in their constituencies no I mean Claire
do you see it as shamble because Kevin
puts I mean Kevin mentioned that it's
back to the 2019 manifest so isn't it
yeah so exactly I mean it was one of the
first things Richie soon act did to tear
up the Legacy um of Liz truss fracking
was one of the key things that she that
she backed and her business secretary
Jacob Reese Market was his sort of pet
project and it was wildly unpopular
among her back benches so Richie's
seeing that kind of coming in now and
saying that it won't happen it's
probably quite a wise decision for him
um there will still be issues and how
exactly energy is is is then sourced but
um fracking things definitely not one
that was was going to stick around now
and kind of stay with you now and bring
up the front page of the times and this
is what two days into the job where she
soon like seems to try to get on the
front foot here
um looking at education just tell us
what what this headline's about better
education be our Silver Bullet uh sunak
is quite the same
yeah so um this is this idea that he's
going to going to introduce some kind of
British Baccalaureate and go back to a
kind of real real sort of
um uh you know like math English keep
everything really simple and um make
sure that you know Britain is equipped
with the skills it needs
um obviously one of the main things
holding back Britain's growth is that we
don't have enough skilled workers and uh
Rishi sulak has pledged for education at
the center of his government and to make
that a key pledge so that it's clearly
going to be one of his priorities as our
street and Kevin would you make of this
idea then as a as a priority for issue
like looking at the education piece of
course it's a it's a piece that we think
that the labor party would definitely
want to campaign on going into an
election
yeah I think every political party every
government every Minister every MP
you've always said uh education is a a
priority uh of course it was just at the
weekend that education leaders said
there's a two billion black hole in uh
schools in England uh it was equivalent
of having a sack five teachers in in
every secondary school and spending per
people is below the level it was in 2010
when the concert was first came into
power at the time in the uh condemn uh
Coalition with a Liberal Liberal
Democrats but soon act it was backed by
the times they've had an education
commission uh speaking to lots of people
exploring uh options and where you can
go forward and I think uh he's trying to
Curry favor with that uh that paper I
think here but what what are the
practical proposals he will come up with
because it is right as everybody else is
that prosperity to a large degree will
depend on having a very highly trained
motivated educated Workforce in Britain
we're not going to be able to beat any
country in a race to the bottom in pay
in standards uh which sometimes I think
he's also uh rather attracted to
certainly in terms of deregulation but
you want to see what he's going to do is
he going to fund it because as I say 2
billion two billion Gap at the weekend
just stays on the education piece if we
can for a minute Kevin as well I mean
former education secretary David Blanca
and the labor party was on the radio the
other day with exactly this that we need
to reinvest in our education so it will
be an interesting sort of battleground
you think going into the election
because as you rightly say all
politicians all of every political
stripe definitely want to see education
as standards improved
yeah and he himself had a very good uh
education he's his parents paid for it
he had it but you know you want you want
everybody to be educated well and
there's something like uh I think is it
a quarter or a fifth of uh kids now
leave school uh really without uh
hitting the uh required uh required
grade so yeah it will be a Battleground
and it should be a Battleground
um because we we need a better educated
country partly as a Workforce but we'll
also be happier more active citizens but
again I'd like to see what he will say
now the the times like it he's backing
their their campaign but you've got to
see the color of these money and the the
words of his commitments yeah we'll
certainly see that maybe on the 17th
November unless they put it back again
right let's move on to the front page of
the Metro now if we can claim that the
picture story will come on to the uh
the story there about the World Cup
later but the picture story here this is
all about how the new prime minister
Richardson did at the dispatch box today
uh I mean how would you score him Claire
well it's his first pmqs and um his back
benches are rapturous but what was quite
nice to see at PM Keys today was
actually two leaders who have their
parties united behind them it's it was
so rare to see such a sort of
electrifying atmosphere at pmqs and
we're sort of used to Ashland faces
um when Liz trust delivered her mini
budget and towards the end of Boris
Johnson's regime and also when labor you
know the labor Batman is behind Corbin
never never looked that happy and so
it's quite nice today to see everyone
really up in arms about everything and
Richie sunac was he was fluent he was
quick he was fast he was clever and
Kirsten had quite a few good jobs but I
don't think he landed any proper blows I
think celak had all his back benches
behind him cheering for him it was a
very good atmosphere today Kevin
no the Home Secretary Sue Ella bravaman
was a big blow by uh
by KIA Stormer
um asking why she was reappointed six
days after being sacked by Liz truss for
a security breach and had any senior
civil servants officials uh warned
against it and he avoided uh answering
that question did the uh the Prime
Minister because there have been
warnings and tonight uh Jake Berry uh
the chair and conservative party at the
time said there were multiple preachers
with a ministerial Court involving the
cyber security by Zoella bravaman and
she only owned up after she was
confronted by it now I think I think
it's a very bad appointment by the the
Prime Minister and he'll come to regret
that so I thought a blow was landed
there I think another blow was landed on
on Dom's he could raise 3.2 billion if
you end the non-dome status of people
including Rishi sudak's wife or who
didn't say that specifically said said
St Thomas and I I thought starva wonder
about he was he was up he's up for the
fight
um and I think
he was competent and he certainly had
his MPS on on his side but he's going to
be on the back foot now and if he's
going to break links with benefits and
with pensions and you're going to be
cutting Public Services those pmq
sessions could get pretty pretty tough
for him Okay Kevin plenty more to come
from both to you after the break thank
you very much for that don't go anywhere
I'll be back with you in a little while
now fire up the fiesta will bring you
more on the Ford Motor Company's
decision to scrap their iconic little
car
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview With Me Now Kevin McGuire
associate editor of the Daily Mirror and
Claire Ellicott acting Deputy political
editor of the mail on Sunday uh Kevin
Claire thanks again for staying with us
through the brightness go for the front
page of the Daily Mail now we'll start
with uh Euclid uh your sister paper
cousin paper however you want to
describe it and this is about the
headline there rishi's migrant crisis
headache tell us uh the reporting on
this
well this is um one of the one of the
bigger problems in Rishi sunak's inbox
and there's then the commons um on the
commons committee today has met the home
Affairs committee have met and um has
declared the Asylum system overwhelmed
by the number of small boats coming into
the country and
um this this report is you know it's
it's going to be troubling for issues to
that and one of the big things in in
polling is often that you know people
are really concerned about the small
base crisis and the number of migrants
coming to the UK and um it's going to be
a huge headache for him as Wella
bravaman he's reappointed her the um
Home Secretary so it will be in her
inbox to deal with and you know the
government has been set by problems with
this they've been unable to to kind of
sort the problem out and um you know be
attempted to to send Flights back to
rwan to Rwanda but that's not happened
that's been kind of set back by loads of
Court problems and so it's it's just one
of those things that's not going to be
going away anytime soon I mean you say
Court problems illegality as the court
described it right Kevin I mean it's the
answer to send them to a one and
obviously we swear to Braverman if she
stays in post that will be her solution
to this
yeah well she dreams of it doesn't she
uh she may never do it it's incredibly
expensive and it may be an unworkable
policy but if you know we discovered
today what 10 12 000 have come from uh
Albania you're not going to send them to
Rwanda if you're gonna send them anyway
you'd send them back to uh to Albania so
in some ways Rwanda is is a distraction
it might incite some people uh to make
it appear the government's doing
something about it but it's not really
tackling the problem but border Force
said of that those uh albanians which
was estimated between one and two
percent of the Albanian population but
aged between 20 and 40. they stay for
six to 12 months work illegally and then
they go home so they are probably
correcting the uh the policy themselves
rather than the government the
government doing it the truth is there
is no easy answer and I think any
politicians who pretend uh that there
are or just deceiving the public okay
let's move on to the front page of the
Metro the story I said we're going to
bring up about uh the World Cup in Qatar
the headline there means incredible
don't be gay at World Cup
um Kevin just the very fact that that is
a headline in quotation marks is just
remarkable to me I mean what do you make
of what's happened to
uh well James cleverly uh the foreign
secretary James not very clear cleverly
say uh get gay people going to a cat or
she'll have to flex and compromise down
in Street sins shot him uh shot him down
let you go at the World Cup you're gay
you you should be able to behave as you
behave every football match you go to
and I think it's a you got this
completely wrong uh tinnier tone death
uh that that is not that is just not
good I've beaten a Qatar and I know
there are there are risks but we think
hosting the World Cup they've got to
allow all football fans whatever their
sexuality to go and watch a game the way
they want to yeah uh and Claire um just
a thought for you on that and then we'll
move on to our final paper if you
quickly if you can
well I think that James cleverley
obviously hopefully ridiculous and
there's no way that that the government
should be telling um any football fans
how to behave in guitar and gay football
fans you know they should be able to be
themselves as the number 10 slacked him
down it was an absolute error okay all
right the final uh story then is about
the Ford's decision to get rid of the
fiesta Kevin what was your first car
oh God the first I I bought was a mini
Metro uh back in the day and I thought
of getting a Ford Fiesta but the Metro
was was cheaper it was when fiestas were
made in in dagenham but I went through a
West Midlands uh a Metro incredibly uh
durable those costs 46 years
we haven't got loads of time Claire your
first car
um I think it was a Hyundai atolls
actually and I think it broke down about
two months later but I then had the VW
polo which has served me well for many
years yeah well we'll find out more
about those cars in a shorter Claire
Kevin appreciate that thank you so much